being a working professional has taught
me that one should never stop learning
and acquiring new skills I chose simply
learn as a professional certification
program in digital transformation in
partnership with Ford University for
myself
and I've not only gained new skills but
I even got a promotion with a 10 percent
salary high after completion of this
course hey I'm vaibhav chitrao I live in
Pune and I'm a business transformation
professional my long-term goal is to
reach a top management position and for
that I needed to grow my knowledge base
[Music]
I also wanted to change my domain over
from IT and management to business
transformation hence I decided to go
through the upkilling Journey with
simply learn and let me tell you it was
a challenging yet rewarding one
[Music]
agile design thinking prototyping
Affinity diagrams Etc which I believe
are very powerful a lot of my current
work is focused on defining methods and
execution of stuff so whatever was
taught during the design thinking and
agile transformation modules are proving
to be really helpful for me we have to
create a USB for any product to work and
the agile Concepts proved to be a game
changer in that aspect
foreign
I love to explore new places in my free
time and I suppose my desire to discover
new avenues as well as opportunities has
carried over to my professional life as
well I think taking this course was the
right step for me
open mind and try to grasp new
technologies and
considerable to because learning should
never
be able to new ideas and network with a
diverse and experienced set of
Professionals in the industry the more
you will grow
foreign
[Music]